hey guys how's it going so jen did you
upgrade to ios 9 yet no
well i did and everyone really just seen
why didn't you make an ios 9 updating
video because honestly it would have
been kind of pointless i clicked a
couple buttons i took a nap and then it
updated when i woke up although it took
a couple hours i will say so i should
probably do it do you wanna oh i'm busy
getting into the summer but yeah like
maybe later yeah i'm gonna update ios
2 on my
watch
oh hey dad i updated and i love it
my dad approves
it's still under the pot silly
so silly
so we're currently on vacation and the
past there's been i think three or four
times that we've been on vacation when
the iphone is released how did i end up
getting the phone before i don't
remember all i know is
i don't think i'm gonna get an iphone 6s
the day of release oh a little sad about
it
also some of you guys might be wondering
just me why are you not using your rose
gold watch because it is not water
resistant they're at the beach and of
course i don't want to be wearing my
apple watch around the water so i switch
back to this one
i'm not sure which one i like more i'm
having some dilemmas all right apple
watch os2
it's like you guys are here with us on
vacation with the fam
mommy's making
making dinner
daddy's just patrolling
puppies eating dinner
checking for update all right it looks
like i have to download it first okay i
gotta connect wi-fi this is not gonna
work
getting cool for the summer
there so wait does my phone have to be
50 because
homie is not at 50
did you update to ios 9 yet
hey bree hey hello
excuse me did you update to ios 9 yet
no
no no
why not
i don't know
do you have cable on you an iphone cable
where'd it go oh god
you can't do
oh you stink like beat
should i stop your video yeah all right
we're back here i got my phone charging
and now we're going to update
the watch
okay well i'll brb
guess what i still never did uh i was
joking earlier about taking a nap when i
upgraded my phone to ios 9 guess what i
did i took a nap while the watch update
was downloading and i still never did
the update so here we are a long time
later and i still haven't done the
update so i think we should
we should do it now details
update i'm still trying to update my
watch
ready to go
install
talk to you talk to each other
be friends all right so my watch is
still updating uh i am excited to try it
but i was just looking at some of the os
features and i'm kind of excited about
the new watch faces because there's
really not that much
to choose from in the first version so
it looks like there's some fun
little ones and you can actually add
your own photos which is very nice
because i plan on putting my dog on my
lock screen i also thought this was kind
of weird they call the pieces of
information
complications
like that that's what they're calling
what complications i feel like you're
over complicating what it's
what it is i also like this new mode
that it has it's called the nightstand
mode so you basically just turn your
watch over and it'll reorientate the
time it has kind of like this alarm
clock function so when it's on its side
and you hit it it'll snooze so
they're like hey we realized that this
watch needs to charge at night oh my
update is done let's put it on and see
what what we got look at this stuff
isn't it nice
you
have more options of adding friends
which is great so swipe swipe holds
upside down so that looks great i don't
have very many apple watch friends look
at all these apps so much quicker
twitter app any different
you're fast over it they said there's
more colors to sketch
so let's
let's send ed a sketch shall we look at
all the colors that we have
whoa
he
that's the worst drawing ever
i guess it's different because before
you could only draw with one color and
now you're able to draw with more than
one color so all right
i got you twitter's still loading
watch os2
highlight of the
feature load apps faster how about the
weather here we go here's the weather in
cupertino this is the little
10 day forecast
fantastic new york
i like this this looks good oh look at
that condition
okay let's check out the watch faces
oh that's so beautiful
oh wait that's me
oh my goodness
it just picked some random photos look
at that look at me and minnie matt just
chilling oh that's so cute
i can't believe you guys didn't do that
in the first place i still think it's
weird that they change
they call these
complications oh look only you look good
okay you're focusing on my charger
please don't so that's new watch os 2. i
was also wondering what you guys think
of os9 i didn't really make a video as i
said earlier because really there's not
a huge difference i mean even using it
on a day-to-day basis
there's not been something where i'm
like wow am i so freaking glad i updated
immediately i do feel like my battery
life has been a little bit better i do
like when i swipe down it has sort of
these app suggestions of sort of my most
used things which is oh two twitters an
instagram and my messages um but when
i'm looking for applications i usually
type it right here instead of putting
them into folders and knowing where they
are so i just quickly will swipe down if
i'm looking for spotify i type spo and
it shows up so that's
strange but that's what i've been doing
and i'm so used to that i'm also only
sort of
into the uh the new switching function
because i really liked having at the
bottom because i wouldn't be looking at
these screens specifically i'd be
looking at the bottom for the icons it's
a little more difficult for me to sort
of find exactly what i'm looking for
even though they are up at the top
they're just they're teeny tiny with
this update you will not be able to have
the live photos so that is only
an iphone 6s thing so yeah i'm
as you can tell by my watch it's late
and i'm gonna go to bed now so i'll see
you later
yeah that's it bye
puppy get ready for your first ride i've
got a fanny pack are you ready for this
are you ready for this
you're not ready because i'm not ready